in the early hours of a Sunday morning
Julie Ferrara is on an urgent mission
because these goals are an adopted
they're in jeopardy to be euthanized
it's that simple Julie is the founder of
light Long Island Greyhound transfer a
volunteer group that helps move dogs
from the tract homes right now we're
driving to get 6 very lucky dogs we
don't pick the dogs most people if you
said I'll pick a dog they would go by
aesthetics color we don't allow that we
only go by personality these dogs have
traveled south from a New Hampshire dog
track to be placed with families on the
East Coast the dogs are given a quick
walk before being transferred to the van
for a trip to a grooming shop where all
volunteer group is waiting for you ok we
have six it's a small load but I think
it's good it's little candy she's uh a
little scared but she'll be okay i hopes
watch the dog they don't know glass
there's dogs and there's gray hair it's
just very very different because of the
track training that they know nothing of
homework the first time she's seeing her
reflection she's like this is everything
is new it's like a it's like a baby it's
like a it's like a baby it really is
these dogs stay in cages for long
periods of time the only time they let
it out is when they have to relieve
themselves or for racing which is only
about twice a week after three or four
days so basically they're in cages for
two three four five years of their life
the volunteers quickly go to work
getting the dogs ready for the new
owners feeding shampooing and D ticking
this is a old volunteer run organization
they get up in the middle of the night
two three four o'clock in the morning to
be there to help us wash walk feed we
couldn't do it without them we could not
do anything without the volunteers
lemonhead was supposed to go to a foster
home but halik locus one of the regular
volunteers decides to adopt her and give
her a permanent home she absolutely fell
in love with that dog my husband said oh
we have to do it in a very serendipitous
option and she's not spoken for sorry
serendipity right oh she's loving that
maybe maybe you'll change your mind you
won't take this is what happens our
foster dogs don't make it too far into
force the care they want and go you go
well nyla Greyhound transfer we have our
best customers right here the dogs are
once again loaded into the van this time
for a visit to the vet with her examine
and spayed or neutered after that it's
on to be adopted the biggest myth is
that these dogs are nervous hyper
high-strung totally totally wrong that's
our we call them 45 miles an hour couch
potatoes
they appreciate what you give them
Tuesday is adoption day families and
dogs file in and the paperwork is filled
out I'm putting a copy of your adoption
agreement right into your folder after
the checks are written and new tags
issued the adoption is complete you
lemonhead is now officially part of the
family and she's going home for the very
first time